this episode of ear biscuits is brought
to you by loot crate calm / rhett and
Link loot crate is a monthly
subscription box service for epic geek
and gamer items and pop culture gear for
less than 20 bucks a month you can get
six to eight items valued at least forty
dollars that's a pretty good deal like
'sons gear apparel collectibles unique
one-of-a-kind items and more this is
like if I were to try to surprise you
with things that I thought that you
would like linked in a little box every
single month but I feel like that would
make our friendship awkward I don't want
you to get I'd rather get a blue crate
right yeah let's not do that let's not
complicate things let's just do it
through loot crate this month's theme is
spooky / scary cuz it's October so we're
talking like zombie stuff we've heard
that there are exclusive Walking Dead
items that will be in the loot crate
this month as well as other things make
sure to head to loot crate comm slash
rhett and Link inner code rhett and Link
to save 10% on any new subscription now
on with the biscuit welcome to ear
biscuits I'm Rhett and I'm link ladies
and gentlemen welcome to the season
finale of season one of ear biscuits
more about that and the start of season
two at the end of this biscuit but for
now it is time for another conversation
with someone interesting from the
internet and what better way to cap off
season one of your biscuits then to talk
to the world's most popular youtuber he
is known as PewDiePie and he is actually
in real life known as felix share by
what did he just was that your that was
RIT's attempt to add and like an Alex
Trebek pronunciation
well I I'll tell you how I got it okay
it looks to me like it should be said
Kajal burg but I know that's not correct
so we listen to a Swedish person online
say his name and it sounded like a shell
body so that's how I'm gonna say it from
now on
anyway you probably heard of him
you've probably seen one of his videos
because his videos have been seen 6.25
billion times there are about seven
billion people on earth to put that into
perspective
31 million plus subscribers on YouTube
yeah it's it's pretty mind-blowing
what does Felix do he plays video games
he does let's play games which is a
whole genre of playing through a video
game while including the commentary by
the gamer and Felix has a very unique
sense of humor and the delivery that you
kind of have to experience in video form
to fully appreciate I mean we are gonna
play a clip but it's it's so visual that
isn't it's not gonna make sense so
you're gonna have to go to his channel
but I'll play it anyway this is happy
wheels part one it's got over 15 million
views he's playing the game happy wheels
and I think he's chosen a dad and his
little son on the back of the bike in
this ultra violent hilariously odd video
game world that I choose you I will make
you proud some don't worry it's kind of
yet again a little kid died poor kid now
that my bicycle you can't kill my sound
like a bicycle so you get a little taste
of the the style of humor there
now obviously huge success with all
these people who subscribe and all these
people who watch but even in a midst of
all that success a good portion of
today's traditional media doesn't quite
get or isn't incredibly excited about
PewDiePie including varieties Andrew
wallenstein who said quote he is a
gibberish spouting clown who's bringing
Western civilization to a screeching
halt ooh okay so we talked to Felix
about this we asked him what he thought
about it we picked his brain about it
because hey that's an air biscuit we
also got his backstory and lots of
interesting details they're dropping out
of college his first job flipping
burgers being a harbor captain meeting
his girlfriend through Facebook and then
their awkward first IRL meeting and we
talked about dealing with the immense
pressure of being the number one
personality on YouTube including where
does he go from here here it is our ear
biscuit with
beauty pie well 6 times 2 is 12
okay why I got a no-mess well you don't
wanna know math know that mmm
one of the things I wanted to pick your
brain about was the art of the running
commentary mm-hmm
you guys do a lot of that well I mean
we'll go for but there's two of us we'll
go for 10 minutes yeah but we're talking
to each other yeah as well as the
audience mm-hmm
what what's your approach to I mean and
then you also edit your work so it's not
like yeah it's not old it's not like it
has to be live from start to finish but
there's but there's still this thing of
if I watch the raw footage I assume that
it would be with any particular game
you're just running commentary just from
start to finish and no that's not it at
all
okay you I usually shoot like an hour
and maybe I'm active 20 minutes of those
like I'll save my energy between the
times I know that I'm not having to talk
cuz I see like three three stuff a day
and then I get really tired please okay
I see my energy for that one is so where
you start getting when we see a video
we're kind of getting the things that
you said we're not necessarily getting
news like oh I cut out so many funny
things and it's no I was actually just
playing the game at that point that's
come it depends on the game a lot like I
couldn't tell you exactly but there are
certain games that you'll play the game
for sixty minutes straight mm-hmm but
then you'll kind of know mm-hmm I'm at
this point in the game I got something
I'm turning it on is that is that which
how you're describing it yeah and then
okay that's over I died or whatever and
that was a really funny moment I know
I'm gonna edit out there yeah so I can
I'm gonna keep playing the game and get
back to something or what I mean all
these mechanics are happening in your
mother I guess I just have an idea okay
now I have enough material for editing
into a video that's it real early but
sometimes I do just 10 minutes uncut -
which is
liyan nice I don't have that today
mm-hmm that's the best now is this you
know because I think there's a lot of
people who are like I could do that I
could do that well they probably could
well but the difference is is the one of
the differences will get into your
perception on your success I mean we're
gonna talk about that but just the idea
of the ability to fill space I think
that's one of the things that has
allowed us to do what we do a good
mythical morning it's almost like a
radio DJ kind of yeah aptitude is sort
of oh but there's like I said there's
two of us
so we're kind of constant playing off
each other is that something that just
characterized your life in your
conversation like are you the guy
the in public when something is
happening you've got something to say
are you the guy that when you're
watching a movie with a group of people
and people it's like you're watching
with your friends and you're kind of
making observations are you one of those
kind of guys only with my close friends
yeah
like I am with my close friends I'm like
that but if people I don't really know
that well I'm just like I am right now
pretty chill again I would say yeah I'm
not like in my video it's kind of crazy
persona going on but also a thing that I
noticed it's when I have when I play
with other people it's so much easier I
don't have to think about anything we'll
just play and it comes naturally kind of
like you you to play off each other
naturally right say but when I do alone
I do have to like kind of make an effort
take another step and that's what I mean
we like spending energy yeah those
moments yeah you kind of have to I
always get stole I would say yeah what's
your what's your production like I mean
you sit down you schedule time okay I
know I got to get you know two out a day
yeah
so how schedule it is your time and then
within that game play yeah you know when
you've got what you want yeah but what
are those things that are going through
your mind to to kind of craft okay I'm
turning on turn there's so much so many
factors that's such a hard question yeah
it really depends on the episode clearly
some stuff will take ten minutes to make
some stuff will take four hours five
hours six hours I don't even
and that kind of that's how you
compensate but I I do try to make two a
day no matter what so sometimes you have
to be creative with a I don't know
another time
are you ever thinking I mean is it all
as raw and impromptu as it seems
yeah there's never a ok I played this
game before or and I wasn't screen
capping it but I kind of know if I do it
this way this will be funny yeah yeah
that happens there actually yeah
absolutely
can you give an example um okay maybe I
discovered something in the game that is
really funny and then I can deliver the
line to that in a good timing you know a
lot of comedy is just timing
yeah I'll do it again you remember a
recent time like in a specific game I
think the skate videos so they're very
like edited and cut and they're really
crazy and stupid so I would say those
but I don't know and you just and you
mentioned you know comedy 2 which is
which is something that is interesting
to me because I definitely see you as a
comedian I think when people describe
you I write you update they call you a
gamer yeah I guess yeah I we get the
sense that just whenever you know we
research everyone that comes on the show
and so we go beyond just watching your
videos that we've seen we we see what
people have said about you and what
their perspective is and there's a
traditional media perspective which
we'll call you a guy who plays games you
know we've been on this platform long
enough to know that there's a lot more
going on than that yeah so just the when
you said comedy it was like okay alright
that was just a little insight into
seeing that I know what I'm doing here
yeah I'm entertaining people i ISO is a
gamer or comedian or as a comedic gamer
or is it coming a gamer will make sense
that would probably make more sense yeah
okay well that's you're officially I
don't know yeah come on BBC or where I
live in new gives it a always pick
something up that's why right alright so
let's go back to the beginning of Felix
not PewDiePie but Felix
so where did you grow up tell us about
the Swedish lightish fjords and we don't
have periods actually that's Norway you
get us chocolate we have a lot of
chocolate no I grew up in Gothenburg
have you heard of that you've been there
have you guys been in Sweden no no have
you guys been outside of a mistake yes
we have we have not been to Northern
Europe so describe the town I mean is
this a so is this a city is it rule is
the second largest town in Sweden okay
and it's we call it little London
because it's always bad weather hmm
soggy yeah it's very gray very dark and
very depressing that's like what we have
in Sweden I'm surprised you guys didn't
pick up on that would like we have
depression that's not our thing well and
not only because of the rain or whatever
but aren't you really close to the
Arctic Circle and so it's our camp so is
there a period of time during the year
where it's just these are all the time
not all the time but like it's I'd
rather prefer they're dark all the time
because wait how short do the days get
in winter time I ate till maybe Sun Goes
them like it gets dark in 3 or 4 that's
like the worst yeah wow so it's
basically like the time that you would
typically be cool yeah exactly so you go
home and it's dark you go to school it's
dark so I was like I don't know I I'm so
it's weird I shouldn't talk about bad
about where I come from but once you
leave your your hometown bubble I would
kind of call it and you see the world in
a more open space I just felt like
what's the point of God okay that was
nice I spent some years ever in like
there's a whole you but you spent the
formative years you know and so I mean
we should be more grateful but no but no
but just whether you should be grateful
or not and that's up to you but was
there that sense yeah that this is a
bubble I want to get out of no not until
I got out of the bubble out guys yeah in
retrospect yeah so what was what was
childhood like I mean did you what did
your parents do
my mom was actually CEO of the year
she's like a businesswoman in Sweden um
uh what like what type of business she
would do all the IT for this retail
company okay yeah cap ball it's kind of
like H&M okay yeah for older people CEO
of the year was this like a like a
Swedish award yeah no wow so it's pretty
good proud of her business
businesswoman mom and then same with my
dad literally and he was a CEO - yeah
and then what kind of company was he CEO
in it would they do like stuff that
monitor how much internet you're using
and stuff okay but yeah they made me
kind of I was in the statement like I
don't know what to do with my life like
all youtubers I feel like from a young
age well yeah like before YouTube or
whatever I was like not from a young
young age I went anyway I wanted to do
games from a young age I would say so
Ewing hmm thing I knew from one and in
what capacity like make game I wanted to
make games yeah that was my dream okay
but I just disappeared I went in my
teenage years and I'm like I don't care
about anything like typical teenager so
I went to the same school that my
parents went and I just realized this is
not from college college at University
okay okay but so you went to college
thinking that you were gonna one day
I'll be a CEO of a company just like my
parents so basically like business II
studies well it's a very broad education
it's like they kept telling me that you
can do other stuff you can do whatever
you want but I just didn't see it and I
couldn't relate to my classmates at all
like to them like video games what is
that something people do and I don't
know that's like my one thing if I talk
to people and they like I can't talk to
them that's like my only thing like my
only subject like I when I get a haircut
you talk to your hairdresser and it's
like what are you doing I'm like I am I
play video games for living there's like
oh yeah I used to love SuperMario right
that's it that's as far as our
conversation goes but him so in cod yeah
you were spending most of your time
playing video games you were like yeah
what was it like an obsession I guess
yeah I was so into the cliche World of
Warcraft like yeah I spend probably too
much time with Mike to the did it you
know kind of cause your social life to
go away or yeah I would say so
really yeah I took over my life I would
say what are you demons go for a while
so you were I mean you were into video
games that insulated you was it were
there any other factors
personality-wise like would you were you
an introverted not really maybe a little
bit but not that much no so you just
like games I just like games yeah and I
had so much fun I like great memories a
lot of people like oh that's so sad
but I'm like no I had an amazing time
that was great like right yeah I don't
know so did you at what point did you
did the YouTube video start for you in
was that after college or it was during
college during college yeah my second
year I was kind of ready to drop out of
college no matter what happen mmm
because I just didn't like it anymore I
like it in beginning because it was math
and physics I can do that but when you
have to learn stuff that you don't care
about I'm like no okay so then what did
you when you were about to drop out what
was thinking about doing I get in a job
or I got a job at a burger shop a fried
z'n burger for a while two weeks was
this like a McDonald's scenario yeah no
I had my my own kind of like a street
trans thing yeah you had a cart no I
loved that would be also a bird no I was
in a break it was kind of like a tiny
shop like a kiosk
yeah like a kiosk that's a that you rent
no no but I worked alone there yeah okay
so a guy who used to work there and he
wanted someone to take over it so it's
like you work here now and you made
burgers
I'm the burger just yeah and that was
that was I'm you I'm done with college
I'm a I'm gonna do burgers
why yeah why my friends they weren't
really too excited
oh yeah what was that conversation like
uh it was pretty bad
because I I still lead you to by that
time but no not even me saw that as
something sustainable or that it could
be something I couldn't even make money
out of it right my things so you tell me
about that conversation yeah it was my I
remember it when my dad specifically
okay
I don't know Morton I don't remember the
words I just remembered the
disappointment and like you're you're
gonna have to get a job we're not gonna
help you with anything they used to they
had they were paying my rent cuz I got I
it's a long story but yeah they were
paying my rent and so they're like we're
cutting that off and all these stuff it
was a pretty drastic change but for me
it was the right choice like I didn't
want to keep going with it so I but all
you knew was I don't want to do school
this is gonna disappoint my parents
mm-hmm and I every dumb decision it's
probably pretty dumb to do but what was
you tailor the plan or was it just
burgers and I'll get it together later
honestly I think you two was in the back
of my head I wanted it to work out but
it just seems so far off like well
weren't impossible what were there who
are you looking at were there people
playing video games and becoming their
job by that point was this 2010 it must
have been yeah 2010 yeah I mean there
was the big ones like revenue Johnson
Shane Nelson and it was really big and I
knew they were making a living out of it
but like there was no big big gamer or
whatever and nobody was doing a let's
play format that was like really
well-known and that yeah no no it was
more of a sub thing to do I would say
there were the color Duty was big that
was a machinima or whatever that kind of
stuff that was big that was it so
literally the machinima channel yeah
that was it that's a big gaming channel
that was the best and at the time in
2010 would they have personalities on
machinima that yeah hey I would yeah
yeah they promoted a lot of
personalities fritzsche were there
that's so he was - all right who would
that have been at the time seananners
you know him
OC energy oh yeah yeah but you were
looking at seananners playing call of
duty uh-huh and you were thinking just
in the back you didn't tell your dad mm
but in the back of your mind you were
like I've got my youtube channel mm-hmm
I've been doing I've been I've been
playing my games yeah this could happen
yeah so then what was you what was your
approach you're like flipping the
burgers I was flipping burgers into
yourself when I get home this is my next
video was it like really calculated yeah
really yeah it was so the reason also I
I met my girlfriend
Matt's yeah she's from Italy we had just
been talking online and she wanted to
come and see me cuz I seen her at one
time and I needed some money for that so
I was guy like I had to take the job and
they're right and all that stuff okay so
you met her yeah before any of the
YouTube stuff happened yeah all right
well then so give us the details of that
this happened Nosa you met her through
during my summer break yeah from college
my freshman year my stated vacation yeah
exactly
uh second year yeah and she we met
online she wrote me on Facebook and I'm
like this girl was pretty hot you have a
mutual friend or something so the story
behind it is that her friend emailed a
video of mine to her and the email in
the email it said look at this idiot
playing video games in it this so it
like literally that's what I yeah she
showed it to me but anytime that but how
many views how many views did they have
at that time 20,000 I think okay so it
wasn't like oh this guy's just playing
this game with himself and three people
are watching it's like okay this guy is
one of the many people who are doing
this for Matt and he's got he's getting
a little bit of traction the thing was I
did these scary montages like I added in
together this compilation of me being
scared in a video game yeah and people
really like that like that was probably
what
my channel and going and I don't think a
lot of other people were doing that I
think that I finally like I started
doing all this machinima thing like
trying to be seen enters and all these
other commentators that were talking
about call of duty and all that stuff
but I try to be an expert yeah exactly
and then I I randomly tried this horror
game and it just people responded to to
do it right away like the FIR the first
time ever people were like we want more
of this like that never happened before
there were people are watching but no
one really cared how big did it get uh I
think I got like a thousand subscriber
one night over one night which was like
Jesus Christ what just happened because
I think I would featured somewhere and
some some stuff yeah this thing would go
a little viral and I like crazy but and
this was before the burger stand or
after it was during the burger saying
okay so this was this was after you quit
college yeah I'm trying to figure out
how much traction you had on YouTube I
think I had 30,000 subscribers okay so
so you have made some of the montages
yeah and okay I'd be making videos for a
year that's it when you made the
decision to edit together the the scares
yeah and it worked
mm-hmm what was your mentality at the
time were you like I gotta I gotta make
this work
yeah you know I see it working elsewhere
I got to try some things what other
things did you try before no my this the
scare montage same old same I don't but
the difference was that I got my
partnership and that way I felt like
okay I'll have to put more effort in
consistency and make sure there's video
going out every day or whatever okay
yeah and that was a and so - you start
to get some traction people are liking
your videos mmm but one girl doesn't
like your video she thinks it's
ridiculous and she emails it to your
future girlfriend yes and look at this
idiot playing video games
was it a montage video it was a penumbra
and then how did that go from Facebook
message exchange - you were in Sweden
she was in Italy yeah yeah let's meet Oh
so we met early summer and then I was
working at the heart
at the time harbor captain a little more
prestigious than what does that entail
uh just tell boats where to go and they
arrive in the harbor so like you stand
on the shore and point I got I got a
boat myself
well like a mini boat I'm getting really
a rib or you know ribs no oh yeah less
slab of ribs barbecue it no color ribs I
don't know probably a little blood like
a dinghy like a skiff we call it a ding
I don't it's a little it's a little it's
a inflatable boat but it's hard yeah
exactly yeah yeah that's it
so you this is exciting you were the
harbor captain I was the hired uh okay
all right well many reasons but it was
his giant boat called golden eye I
called in and they're like I want to
come we want to come this week and
everything and it this is kind of a
small harbor that I would say we took
care of but it seemed like a cool thing
and we have bigger boat so every once in
a while so I'm like alright I'll set you
up
I'll book this space for you and
Goldeneye gold and I was coming and I
forgot to take his contact details and
it turned out that he couldn't come and
he came anyway and it became a mess it's
like an international incident know
where don't you put such a big boat if
we decide to move a bunch of people it
was kind of like a bad thing so my boss
wasn't she's like you can't handle this
responsibility you'll have to go no more
harbor captain for you more did you have
a uniform
with a hat it was so cool we both are
picturing that hat just so you know
yes sir was that was there a knot
somewhere on the Hat like I said yeah oh
yeah tassel it goes around like The Love
Boat captain Wow yeah all the way I lost
it all like I had it all but I
I lost it but I think it was a good
thing because I think like everyone
every day like I think in my bra it's
kind of like when boys play guitar like
all the girls go crazy it's kind of like
harbor captain all the reCAPTCHA he
rides around on a rib maybe it was
better so how did she came to the harbor
no she was also and I made enough money
from that job by the end of it even
though I got fired I made enough to have
afford going to see her how long have
you guys been talking or dating two
months digitally gonna have month okay
so like 10 weeks and then you're like
I'm I'm coming to you baby I'm coming
baby what's up
so what was that first meeting like it
was awkward it was awful it was like the
most painful train ride of my life
like what do you mean she got on a train
with oh yes so we she met me at the
airport and there's no we had to take a
train back and it was just like think
about it like terrible and her friend
was sorry her friend was there too and
their friend that wrote that message
they you know the unintentional
matchmaker exactly this idiots on a
train yeah exactly
so what was it awkward uh well I guess
the whole thing when when like you you
you you really like someone and then you
haven't even met them in person like
that's a weird thing right
I would think think so yeah yeah I think
it's a weird thing and it felt weird the
first time we met but then once we got
back to her house I got to meet her
parents as well they don't speak any
English of course I had practices like
one sentence in the Italian to make sure
I nailed it like all the train all the
train I'm like yeah me piace they
could've shared the or whatever it's
like nice to meet you or something and
I'm shake their hand I like me the worst
thing I don't even know and I'm assuming
that you guys were communicating in
English yeah exactly
okay yeah and then the end the parents
well but in
you and Marcia were communicating in yes
yeah
and how is that going well how was her
English at the time oh yeah Italians own
they don't have good English no I
literally had to wait like 20 minutes
between each message like I it wasn't
like she was trying to play a game or
something with me like she had to figure
out go to google translate yeah yeah she
even told me later like she made her
friend like make sure that it was all
crying then yeah and then she would hit
Send yeah oh wow so okay so that means
ik the in-person conversation even that
much more difficult
yeah I guess was a friend a translator
maybe I'm dating her friend like oh yeah
she was she was yeah okay so so but then
you overcame the awkwardness mm-hm and
it's not it seems like the things are
going well yeah for the day I mean
obviously you're living together yeah
making videos together yeah as soon as
we we were alone there it was fine the
awkwardness went away we showed a little
kiss and awkwardness get that out of the
way and then there was a long-distance
relationship and then at some point last
year she decided to no early we realized
that we like each other so much that we
wanted to say together but we but
YouTube wasn't really working at the
time he didn't yeah how would I do that
I couldn't even afford going there so
she decided she would come to me she
just finished school so we we moved out
to the slums of Gothenburg and we stayed
there for a year okay that yeah and so
that year the year when she moved up
there I'm assuming that that was the
year that things begin to just kind of
catch on YouTube yeah absolutely so tell
us about that year well he went so fast
I remember all the sudden it just got so
much attention all the stuff I was doing
people seem to care all the sudden
that's how it felt all of a sudden no it
wasn't all the sudden it just it was
very drastically going upwards
everything right in a good pace and I
realized if this keeps up then I got
something going on here
yeah in July of 2012 you reached a
million subscribers two months later you
doubled that million subscribe I don't
even know what happened there in 2012 so
leading up to the July 2012 what what
was it that got that first million was
it consistency of the same thing was it
more the montages what what really got
you off the ground I would say
consistency doing my horse because I
know a lot of people who are doing that
I found something that was kind of
unique and unique concept was it the you
were playing games other people weren't
playing or you were oh yes yeah no
everyone was doing the Call of Duty
stuff like right yeah everyone was doing
the same boring stuff so I picked the
games that were dumb and stupid that you
can make fun of and that made like bad
games makes for funnier videos right
well one of the first guys to play happy
wheels well I wasn't in that way I
wasn't one of the first no but I think I
definitely helped making it so popular I
would say that at least right
that was your approach - yeah happy
wheels definitely helped bad extra
million like people cuz I could kept
doing horror stuff and I realized oh
this is exhausting I have to be scared
like every day it was like emotionally
like hard to go through that and YouTube
should be fun so I'm like I can't keep
doing this is ridiculous and literally
it's funny cuz people hated happy wheels
the first time I did it they were like
what is this is the harder we we don't
like this go away you've changed and all
that and then turn out to be my most
successful series ever so that you
should always listen to what they say I
don't know but you kept doing the horror
and just added to it it wasn't like a
replacement no I kept doing the heart
yeah I guess the thing was like you
remember everyone kept doing like
different channels like yeah different
channels for everything so I was like
should I make a different channel for
these are the things but I'm glad I
didn't I think that's also a thing that
helped me I do everything in one I do my
Friday mm-hmm
I do a lot of different things
what I'd like only a gamer and so once
it started to take off and you were
doing regular videos and you were trying
different things just tell us about the
mindset during that time of seeing it
begin to work was there a shift at some
point where it was just like oh this
isn't this is bigger than I expected and
I'm not exactly sure how to manage it
uh-huh yeah
but not until like a couple million
subscribers oh I don't know it sounds
weird saying that but I felt like I had
pretty decent control over it for a
while but just after a while I realized
like I can make a video saying okay guys
I'm going on vacation now I won't be
making videos for a week and there will
still be videos complaining why there's
that's there would still be people
complaining that there's no videos I
feel like I can't reach my audience no
matter what like I can't reach all of
them hey guys we just wanted to break in
for a few seconds and tell you about our
spots or me undies dot-com / rhett and
Link me undies undies as in underwear
yes but link these are not ordinary
underwears oh I know
super comfortable they look incredible
they're antimicrobial they're moisture
wicking you need that they they're
Maywood flatlock stitching this is the
most comfortable stitching technique in
the industry and they are made with
lensing modal yes that is a thing it is
extracted from beechwood trees if you
want beechwood trees on your bum in your
underwear you need to get me undies it
just basically it means they're
incredibly soft and all this is done in
a completely environmentally responsible
way I'm blown away by these things
you're like geeking out I / I liked when
things are done well but I would say
this is underwear done perfectly I'm not
making it up well that's what they say -
so okay you're disagreeing with yes I am
I agree it is perfect underwear rats
geeking out you you be the judge go to
me on DS comm slash rhett and Link and
get 20% off your first order free
shipping to the US and Canada you don't
have to go to store to buy him that's
the great thing I don't
like buying underwear in a store I feel
judged
no he's you a brief man it's like don't
ask me about it dude yeah just make it
happen over the Internet and why are
they even called briefs I mean they last
a while 20% off your first order me a
nice calm / rhett and Link free shipping
to the US and Canada back to the biskits
[Music]
there's that level which I think you
know a lot of full time youtubers reach
which you know in September 2012 when
you're breaking two million subscribers
and then by 2013 you've got three and a
half million subscribers you're still in
kind of this okay full-time youtuber
super popular top of the charts kind of
place yeah everyone now knows who I am
and what I do but it's comparable and
then it goes through the stratosphere
from 3.5 million subscribers to 19
million subscribers in the same year I
mean I've established I'm horrible at
math but fifteen point five million
subscribers in a year so it's a nuisance
you know I I can understand the
full-time youtuber problem of okay I can
no longer reach my audience mm-hmm but
then you reached a point by the end of
that year that was I can no longer
fathom my audience yeah yeah do you
remember a moment when that hit you when
it when it turned into maybe it's a loss
of control or I don't know it's it's
like when stuff happens online you see
the numbers and and all that stuff but
you don't really get the same impression
of what it is like it's not like I don't
really go out in in the middle of the
street and get mobbed and stuff like
that so it's hard to realize that it it
is actually there's many people who
click Subscribe or whatever and so I
don't know it would it took me a while
they're really right grasp that I would
probably say when I went to Singapore
and I
like hundreds of people waiting in the
lobby because they knew was that an
event yeah I was like a socialist are
awards or something like that okay it's
like hey you want to go to Singapore
yeah that's so cool and apparently I
have a lot of fans in Singapore which I
didn't even could ever imagine and then
all of a sudden I go down to like get
and you key for my my door because it
wasn't working and there's a hundred
fans waiting in the lobby it's screaming
at you and I guess that's when it hit me
like did they tackle you I mean how how
intense did it get so they were sweet
they were cute there they wouldn't
tackle me
I mean maybe but you were but you went
to get your key yeah you went to do it
like a twenty second exercise yeah it
sounds like a lot longer yeah they have
taken a few hours to go they would a
little do they won't let me stay down
there they were like the guards pulled
me up pretty quickly and they're they're
just looking at me like what are you and
it that at that point I guess that point
yeah did you realize my life is not
normal yeah definitely I would say that
point yeah that's a good point and were
you like oh this is cool I'm ready to
ride this wave I was like I didn't know
that this was part of it hahahaha bit of
both I would say yeah it's a bit
responsibility having somebody people
watching you and then it's cool like
meeting fans on the street and stuff
like that it's an awesome good good ego
boost right okay but when you had a but
it had to have felt like a blindside for
it to happen over the course of a year I
mean to break thirty million subscribers
to become the number one to surpass
Smosh if you look at how long it took
Smosh I mean it was a longer ramped up
for the two of them yeah that they got
more time to process it yeah I would
assume so that for you what happened to
them over many years and then they kind
of just okay I'm known I'm we're growing
as YouTube grows then out of like
left-field you come in I don't know
where over the course of a year yeah and
you're you're blowing past them and
everybody else and it had to have been
well like about like you were I was
super
I wasn't yeah of course I was in Italy
at this time too and no one watches
YouTube that well some probably someone
watching this listening today it's like
you know there are now a few but yeah no
so I wasn't really shut off from the
world they're like they they do barely
even have an internet so I felt like I
was pretty shut off from all of it I saw
the numbers I kind of got what I mean
but I never really felt it so I'd never
felt too much for it and I still don't
feel like it's that big of a thing I
don't think so
well unless you know that's something I
want to unpack a little bit is the you
don't seem like a guy who is like I did
this so I could become the most popular
youtuber in the world mm-hmm
but it has happened and as much as you
might want to say like you know I'm just
you know I'm just Felix I'm a normal guy
who this happened to that may be true
but the reality is is that you're you're
not normal right your life will never be
normal the amount of the amount of
people who know who you are yeah yeah a
fan or I can have an opinion about what
you do yeah do you see do you stop and
think about that aspect mm-hmm are you
just like nah I'm just gonna I'm just
kind of I'm just gonna kind of be here
and I'm just a normal guy I'm trying to
be like that but it's hard to not get
caught up in what you just said like
with all the things I think especially
when like I for example a couple weeks
ago I decided to turn up the comments
because there was so much spam and he
got picked up as a news story and you
just get spread up everywhere like it
seemed like a lot of people covered it
and that it's kind of made me feel like
okay like why do so many people care
that I'd turn up the comments to me he's
like not even that big video but
apparently now like I'm I'm I'm in the
spotlight like I'm I'm people pay
attention to what I do and in a way that
I never imagined it's kind of crazy and
that's that's kind of scary to me right
let's in a weird like why do people care
why I don't get well I don't want people
to care in that way no well it just kind
of rehash your reasons
oh the main reason is that it's so easy
to write comments on YouTube and I feel
like people just write a lot of
gibberish like first or haha okay cool
all these things they don't really mean
anything to me mm-hmm it's just words
hmm I can't words out of context I can't
really place it as anything so by
turning off the commons and making
people having to reach out to me in a
different way it cuts out that fat like
those that thing so all the sudden I got
comments from people who made the extra
effort to write something that was awful
yeah thoughtful and meaningful and I
missed that it was a hard decision to
make like I try to find a different
solution for so long with other things
and it just didn't work out and I it's
kind of hoping for YouTube to kind of
fix it a little bit make something like
if I can turn up top comments I'd
probably keep it I would say mm-hmm top
comms is the biggest issue okay because
people seem to exploit it and and I
don't want to give them that Liberty to
do that and it's it's bad for my
community too when when there's a bunch
of gibberish up there I know you're
sending people over to bro army net is
that still happening I'm doing that now
yeah in the forums yeah
to me there's another aspect of this
that my observation is you said that it
opened your eyes to the what your
popularity really means when you make a
decision and not only is it YouTube
centric people talking about it yeah
maybe in YouTube it themselves but it's
the press at large yeah it seemed to be
that open your eyes whereas it sounds
like what went into the decision was you
as a creator making a decision and well
this is this is what I need from
comments this is my interaction with my
fans yeah this is the experience I want
to have yeah but it wasn't this is this
is what it means politically you know
from like a from a creating wave
standpoint I'm not you weren't taking a
stand as like protesting comments in
general yeah you were just a creator
making a decision for yourself yeah but
it feels like dudes are feel like
there's an extra weight to every
decision you make
oh yeah yeah I would love to be number
two
really yeah III don't I don't like the
extra spotlight light like it's not it's
not what I did YouTube I don't care
about attention or anything I'd rather
just like I that's also comes with the
comments like I'm will just enjoy making
videos and have a having a connection
with my fans that's what I get a kick
out of yeah anything else it doesn't it
doesn't mean anything to me so I I just
don't really care about it one of the
positive things of kind of realizing to
use your own word though you were doing
a vlog about the charity that you were
promoting that was the water charity
yeah sorry it's what charity watch at a
morning charity water I just said it
backwards as you were even giving a vlog
talking about that you use the word
power you know I got again you know I
found that I've this channel and having
an audience is power yeah and you want
to I think you actually putting our you
did put power in quotes in air quote I
don't know if I said that but you didn't
say you were but you were kind of
acknowledging that I guess I've got some
power so you were you know you were kind
of making light of it but yeah it is
true yeah it is
I noticed that early especially there
was like king of the web do you guys do
that no but familiar with it yeah yeah
no you know you pull a lot of traffic
votes to this thing and you couldn't be
able to do that without and some kind of
quotation mark power right and I was
like why not use that quotation mark
power for something good what is the
pressure feel like I mean are there
moments of fear or tremendous pressure
that I have to get away or I mean
there's pressure of making videos every
day I would say because you don't really
have that energy to do it every day
everyone has a bad day I'm saying so
some days but yeah no I I love it I love
what I'm doing it's so easy I
play video games we're living so it's
not a complicated and I would say do you
have aspirations to you know translate
this success that you're experiencing
right now
into something bigger from an
entertainment standpoint or is it just
like you know I listen guys is simple I
just want to play games I want to
connect with with my bros yeah
or is it like no no I've got the there's
the PewDiePie movie there's any book
there's the PewDiePie media empire I
haven't really used any of that like
media empire I probably should like I
sell them t-shirts and I think that's it
I don't know that doesn't interest me
but at the same time like you said I
just want to I just want to connect with
my brothers I won't just want to play
video games that's that's it like that's
what I want to do but at the same time
I'm not gonna be able to do that forever
you know there's no way so online
why don't you say that well I I'm
already like you mentioned all the
anxiety and pressure or whatever there
is a lot of pressure there is definitely
and it's I just know I can't do it for
too long I like keep up the daily 2
videos a day that yeah creation there
well not only that but like being in the
spotlight and all that that pressure
it's it's kind of exhausting I would say
yeah it's not somewhere I want to be all
the time well for too long either have
you have you thought about implementing
some some strategies like okay well
maybe I should get an editor yeah yeah
I've thought about that yeah but you
haven't yet I haven't no I everything is
going so fine I don't want to like mess
with it no I get that yeah it would
think we didn't talk about we talked
about your incredible rise to fame was
how do you explain it you know not
you're not the only guy doing mmm let's
play video you're not the only guy who's
making funny commentary right how what
is your best explanation as to why you
are the one that sort of separated
himself in the pack I mean I wish I had
a good answer
it's such a complicated thing to try to
explain
I know a lot of people love to make it
simplified like they'll say oh well he
he's really sure like oh yeah well he
got famous out of these montages or
whatever but it's so many factors into
one thing I would say that you can't
really just say that I would say that I
consistency but I had that's like people
really responded at having a close
connection with my fans which I had from
from the beginning I feel like doing
something unique which kind of lifts me
I'm from this huge market of market but
of gamers right and being a unique
persona I would say that's that's all it
takes
do you think another factor is what's
going on underneath the hood of YouTube
and how it works
even though yeah I think yeah all
guerilla I got a lot of free from
youtube I feel like okay well like once
my channel reached a certain point I
didn't have to change marshal improve
much to afford to keep going like if it
exponentially grew a lot more even
though I wasn't doing anything for it
like I feel like I was riding a three
freeway from YouTube because all the
sudden I'm featured here and there and
all that kind of stuff so yeah I have
YouTube to thank definitely I feel like
I don't know it just happened that way
and we're not really I'm none of us are
privy to how that works we can just
observe that it is working yeah but it
but it was you know it's nothing
something I had consciously like did or
anything like that
Allisyn mood you weren't mailed some
sort of algorithm handbook no I like I
moved from code I moved from Sweden to
Italy and a lot of people thought okay
well he was featured on the Swedish
front page and the Italian front page at
the same time but no it's only football
and they telling a front page right what
does never feature anywhere else and
there's no nothing like that I don't
know like all the sudden like so many
people I don't understand how is it even
possible yeah I look at the numbers and
like thousands of people hit subscribe
every day like how is that possible like
I can't make sense that
you two must be helping somehow I feel
like I can't give myself too much credit
now let's talk about you know the
perception of traditional media now
first of all traditional you know
journalists and traditional media they
don't understand YouTube period right
they're getting it more and more but
yeah they're certain kinda but
specifically you know ok 2013 the
variety article by Andrew Wyeth I think
the topic the title of the article was
something along the lines of if this is
YouTube's top talent we're all doomed
right he described your videos as
aggressive stupidity and psychobabble Oh
psychobabble
they say it's kind of true those things
so you have what's your response to that
perspective I mean that's very I I would
say maybe not him it specifically but I
feel like a lot of traditional media are
very naive to approach the way they
approach it it's a lot more than just
like psychobabble what would you if that
guy was here mm-hmm would you be willing
to say well let's watch this video and
what would you tell him well I mean what
I was hell anyone from from old media
the reason why you to be so successful
is because we have a close connection
with our with our fans like we engage
with them in a different way that isn't
possible with old media it's just people
watch YouTube in a different way and
it's more engaging and it's more
entertaining painting that way and well
wait yeah I don't write we don't have
that wall between the viewer and the
creator like in TV it doesn't that's
that's the success behind it I would say
like no one would care about watching
someone play video games right like why
would anyone watch today it doesn't make
any sense like why would you watch
someone else play video game but maybe
you watch your friend sitting next in a
couch playing video games that's pretty
fun right but that's more entertaining
right and it's kind of like that you sit
next to me and in the couch and we play
video games together and I
I make psychobabble to it well you know
it's interesting because that is that is
a principle at work
everybody can relate everybody of a
certain age can relate to going over to
the guy's house he was good at the game
yeah you know the guy who's good at the
game the guy who had a guy he had a
subscription to Nintendo like all right
guy was like Chad Landrum was that his
name oh yeah you know who had
subscription to Nintendo Power you know
and I had that that was amazing and but
he was yeah yeah he was knowledgeable
but there was no friend who was
hilarious and I was laughing out of my
entertained I think that's an
interesting aspect it's the two
principals meeting it's it's something
that is you know is probably the common
denominator in terms of interest amongst
a whole generation right and then they
want to sit down and they want to watch
that dude play that game and you know
what if he's really funny that's that's
even better I think when you really
think about it it totally makes sense
how do you feel even from the from the
gaming community perspective how do you
feel being essentially the ambassador of
that community you're the guy that
everyone on earth goes and plays video
games with you know what I mean yeah I
guess I am that's kind of weird I need
to step up my game what is this so much
pressure no I mean it's cool it's
awesome no like a I mean but do you want
to shift from being that the most
entertaining friend on the couch to the
spokesman in the role model and maybe a
bit of both
why not have you had pressure to clean
up your content for kids I'd like to do
it but at the same time I feel like I
shouldn't I mean like it's brought like
I just a lot in my videos I don't know
why it's it comes with a video gaming I
guess and I made attempts to try and
tone that down
but it just doesn't work out and did it
never works out in the end and I feel
bad because I know they're all younger
people watching that and I don't want to
like teach them Attica and stuff like
that but at the same time I feel like it
that shouldn't be my responsibility
either I don't know maybe maybe I'm
coming this year but I I just feel like
I shouldn't have to change how I make
videos because of who's watching I
should just make the videos that I
always wanted to make and that's the way
it's fun for me and that's that's more
important to me well it's interesting
that you said you tried yeah you know
was that an external pressure or just
something that you felt like you wanted
to try to do external yeah oh really
yeah my girlfriend is like me swearing
oh okay they kind of external I'll try
this one sweet and she said that helps
when she's like I came when I can't
understand it better
well I know same in my videos people
love winnetka's in Swedish but she
wasn't like saved the kids ears she was
like saved my ears I don't like it right
well well no no it wasn't so much in
videos it was well like I felt bad I
know there's like I don't want to be the
guy who curses a lot I don't like that I
cuss a lot either I would say so yeah
but it didn't take you tried it just I
tried it I even had like this electric
shock collar I'm like a dog and I would
shock myself at the time and I cuz well
I think you needed another person to do
that that's that wasn't available at the
time was that in a video video electric
shock collar account sure that guy few
millions it's pretty funny thumbnail
well let's go ahead no I don't know I up
them and what is it called the current
oh yeah yeah each time and it got really
bad yeah we've been shocked by a number
of things I bet you Han get those views
now proclivity for the be friends I want
to talk about the business side too sure
because it's no care about that it's no
myth it's no mystery that you're making
money hand over
fist that's more anyway yeah so I mean
how does that how does that change your
life and is that just like oh well this
is I don't know how to manage this my
lifestyle not much I would say but it
like I remember when I started off
making YouTube like I was flipping
burgers I had money enough to this is my
girlfriend we lived in the slums and all
that stuff so I wouldn't say much have
changed but it the pressure of having to
worry about if you can pay the rent or
not that's gone and that's amazing to
not do having that pressure I would say
what's did you go out and have a splurge
thing that you were like what's a
splurge like a I'm buying a Ferrari or a
helicopter I'm so boring I and a
helicopter I'm very I would love to well
you should look into it I can fly to LA
it's great yeah it takes a while plus
I'd recommend you get someone else to
fly the helicopter I need a pilot to buy
the pilot with the thing yeah I'll
probably do that but no was there a big
ticket item I got my computer ok I'm a
nerd like that's all I want I want my
computer and the Rice's I'm good like I
can I don't care about much right yeah
and what about you know I know what
you've said in the past that ok I'm not
really I'm not really interested in the
branded video thing I used to be so
worried about branded stuff like I would
used to be so worried what people would
think and like the homeward sellout if
people would call me that I would that
would just be like the worst thing ever
but then I realized people are calling
me sellout even if I don't even do
branded stuff yeah I can literally
promote stuff that I do is love and
people like how much do they pay do you
link this yeah right so I was like we'll
get it I'll just do stuff that seems fun
and that's been great I love it like I
did the thing where I got to go through
the catacombs and do like a horror send
there and if it opens up cooler
opportunities and why not like a
yeah I got over that it's not that bad
people people are so they had the
wrongest idea of what a sellout is like
if I get label that then it's usually
for the wrong things so it's like right
whatever I don't know right I'm a
sellout there you go you're talking at
two sellouts I guess one other thing in
the business category is your sign with
maker but why would you need to be
signed with a multi-channel network in
general the thing about gamers is we're
kind of forced into a network YouTube
doesn't want to partner up gaming
channels so I was kind of forced into a
contract with machinima that's the only
way I could have ever and that was like
it like amazing with that came that I
can monetize my videos finally like is
because of the licensing of the video
yeah the licensing of the video games no
one wants to take that so they make the
network's do that and then you know
there was a lot of bad stuff with that
and all that stuff yeah yeah what it so
what was it like what was the conclusion
of that that was there you have to share
a certain amount with the video games I
don't know anything about that well the
bad thing about it was that the
contracts said they was perpetual so you
would suddenly sign up like forever your
channel to this company or whatever and
they would take a large cut out of your
paycheck and that's the only way you can
make any money yet so it was and they
would like the only thing so it was a
really bad thing and it's a shame I
would say and it's still pretty bad for
smaller channels cuz they're forced into
networks they don't that much yeah but
there has a mission but necessarily been
a resolution to the whole copyright good
and it was I don't know if you heard
about that it was like a big fall out a
couple months back YouTube changed
something and then all the sudden
people's videos were flagged left and
right like crazy like half of their
videos will get taken down because they
got flagged by these random gaming
companies and even the gaming companies
didn't name you know
happening because YouTube changed
something and it got messed up did that
affect you
luckily no because I I'm gonna be
channel I'm more protected that's that's
a good thing about the networks they
would help with that but they wouldn't
help I ever won with that so it was kind
of a chaos I would say okay yeah but
basically it's YouTube takes a certain
percentage of ad revenue associated with
every one of your videos yeah and then
with a normal creator with no copyright
issues they would take the remaining
percentage themselves yeah and maybe cut
in an MCN if you wanted to work through
an MCN yeah but for if you're playing a
video game
yeah the video game maker gets now some
percentage it's a it's kind of a game
maker doesn't make any money off of your
well he banks money of the sales or she
makes extra money of the sales that
hopefully cuz you're promoting the video
I had a good game yeah I made a lot of
games successful like I said like that
but it's true there has no doubt
absolutely no doubt yeah there's been a
lot of game said like skate 3 for
example they had to that's like a five
year old game or something like that
yeah and they're restocking those right
now because well it's it's interesting
like an argument could be made that oh
if the guys like us put a certain
product in the video yeah and which
people will pay us to do yeah it's like
that without getting permission the
product is mad about yeah because more
people didn't go buy the product I mean
that's that's a it's a bit of an awkward
thing I would say I mean in in some
sense it kind of makes sense that they
would get paid because we're kind of
using their craft to like my videos
would not exist without their game like
there's no way they'd be fine without me
but even though they benefit a lot
without me they'd be fine without me I
wouldn't be yeah but it's not them so
right but it's it's mutually beneficial
yet it I'd it's definitely mutual but I
still feel like I have to be humble to
that fact that well yeah well the world
that's the thing no matter how big you
get or YouTube gets yeah if they decide
listen we are going to fight this battle
and we're gonna say no we're gonna file
a copyright claim for everything they
could shut it down yeah
but that would never happen there would
still be people who realize okay this
guy can play my game that would be huge
for me
so they would let me and they YouTube
couldn't take control out of that so so
the games that you're playing and pretty
much across YouTube the games that
everyone's playing they're not the those
video game manufacturers or whoever's
involved in that whatever they own
they're not getting a part of your ad
revenue no your response is well they're
just they're getting free promotion for
me yeah so that's the flip side of it
yeah but does this impact what games you
decide to play in what not to play
personally or professionally the thing
is like I have very different tastes of
games when I play for you to burn myself
I like something more engaging and more
story driven and stuff like that but I
usually this isn't too well on YouTube
but at the same time it's more fun to
make commentary over really dumb games
so you choose based on its kind of cut
the comedy and your perform yes you can
get best performance basic and get the
best performing videos uh-huh but it's
not a business decision I mean I mean
I'm not gonna it is I mean that's that's
a bit in terms of I'm I'm not gonna use
this game because I don't want to
promote them Oh or I want remote I think
it's been a very none often enough that
I would like know anything to say about
it happens yeah so looking into the
future mm-hmm you kind of hinted at I
can't do this forever well I mean what
do we expect should we expect more
should we expect different should we
expect the same should we just be
waiting for you to quit you're gonna
retire like in the next six months are
you just gonna say that's it no no it's
we're not I'm not there I'm just saying
I I would love for someone else to take
the number one and I can kind of just do
my own thing but not so much in the
spotlight who's gonna do that I don't
know can someone just I mean do you look
at the charts and you know it's not
gonna happen we're not gonna do that
please so you don't have a prediction or
a secret well honestly what I think is
gonna happen is next year I'm probably
going
to get an editor and I'm probably gonna
have to look at it differently for for
my sanity I don't say no doubt yeah and
I think yeah I'm planning next year to
do make that move but yeah so no that's
only in two months
yeah might be three months yeah I'm not
good at math or calendar so that's your
new year's resolution is get some help
uh well yeah I wanna I want to like cuz
I spend all my time editing that's where
all my might I'm just slings away I
could easily record a lot during one day
and just be fine for a week but I have
to edit it and that takes so much time
so if you succeeded that what are you
gonna do at that time different types of
videos or I wish I could say oh so there
is a something you just can't stay out
of it yeah okay now now we're getting
somewhere
uh-huh yeah I'm sorry I wish I could
like talk about it but wait so we have a
week we can expect a big project from
PewDiePie and 2015 that's exciting
yeah should be fun I'm excited is it
gonna be on your channel I don't know it
could be it could not be is it gonna be
on our channel I hope so it's in a lot
of your biscuits we get to the point at
the end where we just start asking
questions and sometimes it I feel like
we're not well-equipped to ask great
questions here but it's probably it is
probably a movie like a totally
different type of movie that's kind of I
guess no it's not oh it's not I don't
have anything wrong it's it's a video
game link yeah big ha ha ha it's it
video my video game that's pretty that's
I mean I'm probably gonna do that but
that's not it I'm probably gonna do that
I would love to make a video game that's
like been my goal from the beginning
like is it my channel to grow no it's
not I am why not I don't know like its I
want to find someone who's equally
passionate about making it as I am and
that's really hard right you've got to
find a well qualified right do you have
an idea do you know what it would be oh
I have I am like three games that I
wanted me
one would be a horror game because
that's what I do it makes sense but it
would be more story driven and character
interesting because I feel like that's
what a lot of games like they're just
they're just trying to spook you and
that's it and it's kind of boring
everyone I want something moving more
death and try to scare you in ways that
really hasn't been tried before I'm feel
like people do the jump scares and
that's it's kind of getting cannibal I
want something new and I feel like
there's some explored unexplored area
Sarah oh okay um and then I want to make
the PI game for the for the fans
okay it makes sense I don't know yeah I
what would that look like I'd probably
be a rage game like just something to
piss you off or something yeah okay but
you're not gonna get to making those
until you do the big project that you
can't tell us about that we haven't yet
yes so we shoot when trying one step at
a time I get overwhelmed by just
answering emails oh yeah well listen man
it's been great to get to know you and
hear your story and yeah I feel like
I've just been talking to lie I would
love to yes well we'll come on your
product that you're doing I just want
any 15 I have a podcast
well we'll gladly come on it's the
broken podcast yeah a long time you guys
over it's great okay yeah done well sign
the table thanks again for coming in on
signing right now thank you so much I'm
glad to be here it's an honor to write
this signature
[Music]
and there you have it our conversation
with the most popular person on the
platform what a conversation you know
someone who has experienced so much
success I definitely a lot of our
questions were around you know what do
you think about this all this success
how is it impacting you how do you
process this mm-hmm and I definitely get
the sense as we asked him those
questions that well he still is
processing it the this this is a process
that he continues to experience yeah
it's it's uncharted territory to the max
I mean how could you have anticipated
how could anyone have anticipated and
this is not to denigrate anything that
he's achieved or or his work on his
channel but how could anyone have
anticipated the massive level of success
I got the impression that he didn't
either you know and that he isn't
necessarily interested in maintaining
that success at least at the level that
he's at right now he virtually well he
essentially invited someone to come and
take the number one spot he doesn't want
the number one spot on YouTube right and
but that's not gonna be easy I mean the
next personality on the list is hola soy
Harmon and then
Smosh right underneath him and they're
each at nineteen point five million
subscribers in 18.9 so basically you
know 10 million subscribers below
pewdiepie so that's not a number that's
easily made up it's lonely at the top
that they say that for a reason and you
know I think that as he's still
processing it he still seems like you
look at the comments thing and I think
it's a perfect example of he's he's
operating as a as a user as a normal
creator you know not operating as the
as the number one creator on in the
world kind of a thing he's operating in
the way that he wants he wants to
interact with comics in a certain way he
want to end he wants to interact
audience yes not that he's making
decisions as number one a no also he's
not an interest credit he is an
enterprise but he does not function as
an enterprise he is he is an individual
he's a dude he's a dude who's the number
one personality on YouTube and you can
let this dude know what you think of
this ear biscuit please hashtag ear
biscuits and let Felix know at PewDiePie
pew die pie Diep ie with a PE W in front
of it I always spell things totally like
in a way that is totally unhealthy it
doesn't connect the dots for that
PewDiePie and let him know you already
know how it's spelled of his story okay
and that brings season one of ear
biscuits to a close the collection my
collection of season one series one of
ear biscuits is now complete with a
little Felix sliding in there and by
saying season one is coming to a close
what that is essentially saying is that
well there will be a season two when
will that happen well we aren't going to
tell you that right now because we are
still making decisions about that but we
will let you know you can rest assured
that we will let you know via Facebook
Twitter good mythical morning all the
ways that we communicate with you
normally just make sure you're following
us there and you will have a heads up to
know when your biscuit season 2 it's
going to start and I'm not gonna say
that you can provide input into how your
biscuits should be retooled if in any
way but hey you're the audience and you
have opinions and I'm not gonna deny you
the right to communicate those with us
hashtag ear biscuits but I'm not gonna
make any promises that we're gonna we're
gonna deliver on any of those
suggestions but you can you can suggest
away I mean there's a couple of things
that we can rule out from the beginning
I mean things like we're not gonna do it
in flight do it in flight okay we're not
gonna like be recording these while
hovering weightless I was just gonna say
face like we'll probably keep doing it
in English that's one thing I think is
safe to say
it'll probably still be me and Link hmm
doing it
there was talk for a while of link
taking a week than me taking a week
actually there was no it wasn't never
talk of that at all that completely
adult please don't suggest that it'll be
the two of us it will be in English
those are some things that you can count
on we we won't change the name of it to
be risk it's no be risk it says not is
taken already because that's what we
were gonna call it and then we went with
your biscuits right and when I say it'll
be me and Link I mean it'll be us and
then it'll be other people too just like
it has been unless it's not unless it's
not unless it's you know two others
maybe five other people can we make it
any clearer that we haven't thought
about this yet yeah we have to discuss
this offline or we could keep discussing
it here and not only get nowhere but
confuse everybody let's take this
conversation offline that's another
thing that people say in the business
world are off air I got a hard stop on
this conversation I would really go get
my thirty thousand foot view on this
situation and then we can make some
decisions and really the rebel will meet
the road rebel will be rubble the rubble
the rubber will meet the road all right
guys that's the promise and rebels will
meet roads rubble when you say something
like rubble and your meaning rubble like
with a ru b ble it doesn't sound stupid
but if you think that I'm saying rubber
and I say rubble I sound stupid well and
let's not limit it to that statement Oh
see you season two
[Music]
[Music]